bye
hmm
i was in mexico with the c.i.a in the
60s
and
they had a vast operation going there
and especially in their
penetrations and work with the mexican
security services and in fact it started
with the president in mexico our
operations very close relationship with
three successive presidents lopez mateos
diaz or dawson
um when it comes to mexico and this
this zapatista movement there's not a
doubt in my mind that they're in
champions they've been there since day
one i'm sure the national intelligence
service known as sin which the cia
which the cia established in 86 or 87
as a national service to be used against
the narcotics trade coming through haiti
in the caribbean and that area
which in fact turned into a narcotics
dealing organization as they always do
or often do afghanistan is not an arab
country but they had a lot of volunteers
islamic fundamentalists from the arab
countries who went as volunteers to
fight in afghanistan they were they they
were volunteers from algeria from
morocco from all of north africa egypt
to sudan and other arab countries and
they went there as volunteers and they
fought
first they were trained in how to handle
the weapons and so forth
by in these camps provided by the cia
and then they saw action on the front
lines well when it was over
these they're called afghanis in their
home countries because they've gone off
to as volunteers even though they're
from arab countries so these afghanistan
so-called afghanis they went back and
then they started to foment
fundamentalist revolution in their own
country so you see what's happening in
egypt or in algeria right now this
algerian civil war has taken 30 35 000
lives they say but this is
being run and the some of the main
forces there have served in afghanistan
with the bill ticket from the cia
and the training and so forth
same thing in egypt with the
so-called islamic group there and of
these people who were tried in new york
uh on the two cases you know won the
world trade center bombing and the other
the conspiracy trial for the tunnels and
the you know
i think half of those were trained in
afghanistan
phil agee was a cia officer for 12 years
serving mainly in latin america
he quit the agency and wrote his best
seller inside the company he will share
his experiences and insights with us
right now on alternative views
[Music]
hey
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a program i've been wanting to
do on alternative views for 17 years
and that is have an interview with
former cia officer phil agee now we have
had some uh programs with phil
that you have seen some speeches that he
has given that we've had copies of and
presented them to you and on the
documentary on company business but this
is our first chance to actually talk
with him in person
phil was in the cia for 12 years and
then quit after he saw what the cia was
actually doing all the terrible things
doing in the areas where he was working
particularly in ecuador mexico and
uruguay he resigned in 1969 to write his
first big book
inside the company or cia diary
since then he's written
five books the last one being on the run
which tells about his experiences after
he got out of the cia when he was in
europe and trying to write his book and
the cia was hounding him from country to
country doing everything he could to
keep him from writing this book
well phil we're so pleased that you can
finally
be with us i'm very happy to be here
very happy to be here
you've had
such an association with the cia both
positive and negative for so many years
let's start out by talking about where
the cia is today they say they want to
do intelligence
gathering on economic subjects rather
than political etc like they had in the
past what do you think about that well i
think that that's a normal activity
they've been doing that since the
beginning to speak of it as something
new
is
really inaccurate
in this context of all this talk about
economic and financial and commercial
intelligence collection as a new role
for the agency
i
got out a document which was sent to me
anonymously in 1976 20 years ago
practically
and this document
was
it was the
list of the what they call key
intelligence questions for 1975 in this
very field economic commercial financial
intelligence also high-tech
developments and all in the
developed countries all in allies like
the nato allies and japan
and this is a was an innovation of
william colby when he came into the cia
in 1973. he tried to systematize and
organize the foreign intelligence
collection process
and for
1975 there were
i think 69 key intelligence questions
and these are actually
questions
with some detail and then there's a
whole discussion of them that follows
from 1 to 69 but these were only on this
document there were only the
the nine which deal with
economic and commercial and financial
matters and i got that out in and it
calls for great great detail
on all of these matters including the
negotiating positions the fallback
positions on such
negotiations as the general agreements
on tariffs and trade now the wto
and all of it was in its most important
parts
spying on allies
and the state department was supposed to
get this type of information the cia
would get it get it in its way secretly
or through some kind of technical means
or through agents and
so i just point that document out that's
20 years ago and they were doing it for
20 years before that i would assume then
they would turn this information over to
the corporations the multinational
corporations that i can't be sure of
they would
send it in of course to the analysts and
they would then be preparing reports for
use within the government
in the commerce department you know and
within the white house and the national
security council and its staff but the
decision to turn it over to
commercial companies or multinationals
is something which
i i can't really say that they did that
then but we did help the multinationals
in different ways from time to time to
time my very first job
in the cia after the training program
was to
i was assigned to the latin american
division to the venezuela desk
and my job it was it was so boring
i had to do name checks
and a name check is where you get a name
from in this case caracas our office in
caracas in the embassy and you
you make a request for all the records
on this particular person from the
records integration division or rid
that's where the files were
and
then you were looking for anything
negative politically negative in other
words or derogatory
it happened that these lists of names
that i was getting every week
were given to us in caracas by the chief
of security of creole petroleum
and creole petroleum you know was the
largest overseas subsidiary of
esso or now exxon of standard oil of new
jersey in other words and so we were
performing this
security check in order
to help them keep political undesirables
out of employment because these were
people who were prospective employees
for creole
and so we were doing these checks on
venezuelans actually and
serving the interests of of
of this
enormous
standard oil
exxon xso
subsidiary abroad this one example and i
can tell you when i got out of that job
i was very happy because it's just
boring you can imagine to try to go
through all these different records and
look for something that might be
derogatory and then have to write it
back and and the first name i got was
jose diaz
and didn't even have a date of birth so
you can imagine how many how many files
i had on jose diaz
is the most common name
well this is
when they say they're going to start
doing economic intelligence now
and
helping out the
quote u.s unquote corporations they've
really been doing that all along it's
just kind of taking the mask off of it
because everywhere they have the cia has
actually been making the that particular
country safe and profitable for the
multinational corporations and local
elites yes everything goes back to that
and as a matter of fact
this intervention abroad for stability
for the
optimum operating conditions for
us-based multinationals is something
that predates even
certainly world war ii
and in some respects you could say it
even predates the bolshevik revolution
because it's
more than 100 years now that that the
leadership in this country has
understood
that there's no way to preserve the
system in this country
without foreign markets for surplus
production without foreign labor
cheap labor and without the cheapest
possible
national natural resources
and this is something which has been
going on for 100 years
all through the cold war and so it is
something that's going to continue for
the future but in this economic and
commercial area there have been two
cases this year
of operations that went bad
one was in france in february when the
french government
caught the cia trying to recruit people
in the french government for secret
information on french negotiating
positions within the world trade
organization
context and they uh they ordered five c
i a people out of the country
that was the news at that time in
february four of them including the
chief of station
were in the embassy undercover as
diplomats you know and then there was a
fifth one a woman who was outside the
embassy she was under some non-official
cover
i don't know what that was but
that was the news at that time and then
it came comes out much later just a few
weeks ago that as a result of this and
of the
of the
reaction of the french government the
strong reaction to this attempt to
penetrate their government
the whole cia operation in paris in
france was shut down
including whatever they were doing
against international terrorism the
narcotics trade and so forth uh that's
one case that went bad on them this year
uh another one that went bad just a few
weeks ago was the uh leakage to the
press which wasn't eventually confirmed
it's true
the cia was spying on the japanese
negotiators last summer in the trade the
auto talks
you know how we're trying to get into
their market and so forth and the cia
was monitoring the communications i
believe of the japanese negotiators and
the appropriate ministry and also the
companies themselves so that our side
that's
the mickey cantor side would um have a
better knowledge of what they would
accept and what they wouldn't accept and
so this has soured relations with japan
also so when you get into this area of
spying on your allies
you're asking for a lot of trouble
and whether they give that to the
companies or not it's difficult to say i
can't tell you
of course they've been doing this type
we've talked about the japanese they've
been doing that type of
monitoring of communications and for for
years for decades this is nothing new i
guess it just now came out
yes and uh
as i mentioned it went goes back at
least 20 years and 20 years before that
but one area that ought not to be
forgotten is cuba
because there is a 35-year economic
blockade going against cuba still and
there are those people who are trying to
intensify this and broaden it still more
now
the cia
without the slightest doubt
has the requirement in every
country to report on any possible trade
deals that cuba may be interested in
making
or
investment in cuba now that the country
has opened up
and the cia has got to collect this
information so that measures can be
taken
to
to sabotage these possible
deals of interest and benefit to cuba i
was there last year and i was in a
meeting
being addressed by roberto robina he is
the foreign minister very young
hip guy
and he was telling us that of every 10
possible deals they have for investment
in cuba or for trade and
the united states is able to
squash
nine
and so they know perfectly well that
every move they make as they go around
the world
in in trade negotiations or in seeking
investment
for whatever in cuba
they are being followed and watched
under a microscope so that uh some
measure can be taken it could be the
ambassador with the local government it
could be any way they can
approach the person and put the pressure
on
there's a good example of this for
example
the soviets built a large
petroleum refinery
very near sienfuegos which is the main
city on the south coast
this was never put into operation
before the collapse of the soviet union
and um then there were there was a
diminution in trade and
the cubans finally convinced or made a
deal with the ecuadorians who which are
one of the principal exporting countries
and they were to
bring the petroleum from ecuador to cuba
to this refinery refine the products and
re-export
leaving behind a certain amount of of
production to pay for the use of the
refinery this was going to be a great
deal for cuba because they have an
energy crisis
this terrible
the united states was able to
put the fist down on ecuador and it fell
through
so the cubans made a deal with the
venezuelans because eventually you know
they they nationalize creole and saul
and national industry now uh the
venezuelans then we're going to bring
the petroleum to this refinery and
re-export leaving
surplus production behind for the cubans
the same thing happened bang the
venezuelans had to withdraw
so the cubans went to the mexicans and
the mexicans resisted
and now they are putting it into
operation
so
it's not hopeless but you see how the
united states is going around in these
areas of economics and of trade and of
commerce
and finance to try to
make the cuban people suffer as much as
they can and this is affecting in a
drastic way
very young children and infants and also
the older in other words the most
vulnerable and it is a it is an
eternal shame on the united states in my
opinion that we would do such a thing to
an entire country just because we don't
like the system just because they won't
come under our
protection
basically it's a kind of a mafia
attitude and it has been that way since
eisenhower
well that's capitalism well it's also
the united states and
our tradition of being very nervous when
we don't control something and when a
country like cuba slips out from under
our control
after we had
ruled it practically as a neo-colony or
a protectorate
for 59 years or so
then it makes people nervous because
they know that if the cubans are
successful in their example
of being able to provide as a poor
country
the best medical care in the third world
to the whole population because it's an
inclusion inclusionary system it's not
like we have here where you have this
huge bulk of the population you know
marginalize them but there if everybody
can have adequate medical care if the
schooling
is adequate for all and remember cuba
has
more doctors and more teachers per
capita than any country in the world
and they have succeeded in these areas
and it's all state
supported which means people don't have
to put money out for for the medical
care or for
it's in they of course pay the cost
indirectly as a whole society but they
don't have to pay the bill at the
hospital and so forth and so
that cannot be allowed to stand it's a
very bad example
for the united states and for all the
third world people in the united states
after all
we're becoming a third world country
very fast if not
not already and so there is a
very large mass of people out there who
can look at cuba and say well if they
can do it
and on a per capita income of two
thousand two thousand five hundred
dollars a year where ours is twenty two
thousand five hundred dollars a year
what's wrong with what's wrong with our
system i mean maybe we ought to consider
an alternative
that's why nicaragua sound in eastern
nicaragua had to be destroyed
exactly they were a bad example and
that's why grenada had to be destroyed
because any
um
movement that comes to power with the
idea of providing for all the people
and of escaping the control of the
united states and its
economy let's say the corporations and
so forth then that is bad news
here in the united states in the upper
circles of power
and influence and so
in nicaragua
i watched it from the very beginning i
was often there and
it was it was a very
sad sight
to see the hopes at the beginning
and
the euphoria with the overthrow of this
u.s installed dictatorship from the 30s
on
samosa
and all the hopes for
expanding education and the literacy
program they adopted right at the
beginning it's similar to what the
cubans did health health as well all of
those things cuban doctors were in there
they were setting up clinics clinics all
over the international solidarity
movement was was just
tremendous for nicaragua in those early
years and naturally the united states
could not let that stand and the
economic system was working they had the
highest greatest expansion of uh
of their
national gross national product of any
country in the western hemisphere at
that time that's right that was in the
early years but then
you know the cia started to reorganize
using argentine military officers who
had worked in this uh really
it's hard to find words for the the
argentines you know in the 70s the dirty
war there but these military people from
argentina were taken by the cia put to
work in honduras reorganizing the
remnants of the of the somos national
guard
and then it became a
a huge terrorist operation
and
as a matter of fact at the by the end
when when the killing was
was
stopping in the late 1980s
they had killed something like 35 000
people
and that's one percent of the population
of nicaragua
the comparable figure for the united
states would be what two for 2.5 million
people killed over an eight nine year
period i mean that's more than were
killed in all the wars
that the united
would be a states can you imagine if
something happened to this country where
2.5 million people were killed well it
means in nicaragua there's not a family
that was untouched
i mean
and and they have a huge number of
amputees now in nicaragua and a very
large program for getting
prosthetics for these people because of
the landmines that the countries put
around
and they're still they don't you know
they still haven't gotten all out of the
ground same thing happened in angola
exactly angola's got the very same
problem you know it's well it's where
the cia goes if it happens in one place
it's going to happen in another
the cias
more or less intimate said well they're
out of the covert action business
anymore but i read recently where
they're down in chiapas helping the
government fight the rebels there
there's not a doubt in my mind that
they're in chapels they've been there
since day one i'm sure
and they mexico is just too important to
the united states to leave it to the
mexicans you know what i mean
and
i was in mexico with the cia
in the 60s
and
they had a vast operation going there
and especially in their
penetrations and work with the mexican
security services and in fact it started
with the president uh in mexico our
operations very close relationship with
three successive presidents lopez mateos
diaz or dawson
when it comes to mexico and this um this
sapatista movement what they have to
worry about i think is not just the
armed movement in chiapas of these
this armed force of the ezln
but
as an inspiration they they
triggered the development of a huge
support network
popular movement all over the country
which has come together to support their
demands and the demands are really not
outrageous at all no they're not they're
not outrageous and the societies
themselves i could not believe this that
they say we do not want power
i mean that's the first guerrilla
organization i think that has ever said
that the idea always was to take power
and then
impose or establish
or reorganize do whatever you want to do
but they say no we just want to have
democracy in this country and we want to
get the
pre out
and
the pre is of course so so
unpopular now it's it's it's carrying on
through it's it's a patronage job system
you know that's been in power for a long
time
so in mexico i think they have a much
bigger problem than just the armed
movement
in chiapas but it is spread all over the
country and nobody can tell where this
is going to lead
the southeastern you know had this in
this referendum back in august and
september and they had it not only in
mexico this is a referendum on a number
of questions on the direction in which
the people would like to see the country
move and how they would like to see the
southeast themselves
develop whether they should
convert themselves into a
a an independent political movement
and they had international people i
voted in the thing too because i'm
sitting over there in germany reading
every day through my computer the latest
happenings in chiapas and all over
mexico and so i'm actually very
interested i voted
on all these questions there are a whole
series of questions
and uh people i think they had 80 or 100
000 people outside mexico who took part
in this referendum and there were
several million in mexico who what did
you send out questionnaires to people
all around the country well in in my
case all the questions came on
through the computer through the net and
i sent my vote back through the net
and in mexico they organized tables all
over the country
and people went and and voted
on their preferences according to this
list of questions so
you can be very sure that the cia is in
there in a very big way i imagine
they're in there with special forces of
the united states army
right in chiapas they're doing
communications monitoring i'm sure of
all the uh transmissions of the
zapatistas and monitoring the people who
come and go you know the mexican army
has tried to make put a ring around
the area controlled by the the ezln and
it's a it's a very fascinating scene to
watch but when you talk about
going back to your comment about covert
action in the 1990s
there are some very interesting things
that have come out for example even
though the cold war is over that does
not mean that the united states is going
to settle for democracy in any
particular country they never have
and
the litany is quite long you know
starting from the 50s
of democratic processes
what is accepted here as legitimate
electoral process and pluralistic
political parties and so forth when that
goes against u.s interests they don't
kill
they don't care i mean it's not a matter
of principle for them the principle is
what's good for us
what about fate what's that famous
remark that kissinger made about the
situation in chile
oh we shouldn't stand by
because of the
irresponsibility of the chilean people
and at the same time zen nixon was
telling the cia to make the chilean
economy scream
but what has happened now in the 1990s
is that
in 1990 bulgaria
the bulgarian communist party the former
communists they renamed themselves as
the bulgarian socialist party
and they won the 1990 elections
in the sense that they took 211 of the
400 seats in the parliament
do you think that the united states
accepted that all these international
observers were there from western europe
and other places and they all said this
was absolutely free and fair there was
no fraud at all that we could detect
but the united states didn't accept that
and so nowadays instead of having just
the cia going around behind the scenes
and trying to manipulate the process
secretly by inserting money here and
instructions there and so forth
they have now a sidekick
which is this national endowment for
democracy nad
and this organization dates from 1967. a
lot of people don't realize because it
was just established in i think 83
or so but the idea
emerged from a series of scandalous
revelations in 1967 the worst ones to
that point to hit the cia and i was
in headquarters at the time that these
scandals broke and the gloom there was
something you could you could touch
almost because what happened was
the
the long-running cia's control and
manipulation of the international
program of the national
students association in this country
which was the national organization of
university students
came out it was revealed
and that led to revelations of a lot of
other cia operations because they were
using the same bogus and real
foundations to channel money into all
these different overseas organizations
and i remember very well that time
magazine at the time or newsweek i think
it was time
they published a wheel
with all these spokes going out and the
cia was it's the center and then halfway
out where all these these corporate
these foundations
and american organizations and then out
at the end were the foreign groups that
got the money and the instructions
naturally they don't give away money
without being sure that it's spent the
way they want it's been and so
this was a catastrophe for the cia and
the next month or the month after that
this would hap started in february 67
and then by april i think it was dante
fachel the congressman from florida was
proposing the establishment of a
an open system to
finance these overseas organizations and
we're talking about some government
organizations abroad some political
parties
some media
organizations youth organizations and
student organizations all these kinds of
of so-called pluralist organizations
when in fact they weren't really free
organizations for because to the degree
that they take money and instructions
from the c i a to that degree they're
not free at all right but anyway fascia
came up with this idea but
nothing it didn't go anywhere because
the so-called consensus between the two
parties had broken down over vietnam
and so it wasn't until the early
eighties when reagan made his speech in
the house of commons about the democracy
project worldwide that this began to
take on steam again and finally they
decided to copy the german example
each of the major german political
parties has a foundation which is
financed by the german government
before it was west germany now the whole
country and
for example the friedrich ebert stiftung
is the
sbd or the social democratic party's
um foundation and they finance projects
all over the place and for years in the
fifties and sixties and i would guess
even into the seventies in fact i know
into the seventies even to the uh early
eighties the cia was channeling money
through these german foundations abroad
for example some money a lot of money i
think it was a million dollars in war
but i'm i'm a little hazy on the amount
but anyway it went through the it was
cia money who which went through the
conrad adenauer stifle that's the
christian democratic union
it went from there to evipo which is a
foundation of the
copay the christian democrats in
venezuela
and from there it went to the christian
democrats in el salvador to duarte
for use in the elections i've forgotten
which year maybe 84 or something like
that and it was traced some journalists
did this and
so that is the way they would use these
german foundations in the past so now
we've got our own we don't have to use
the germans unless we really want to
anymore because in 1984
we established this national endowment
for democracy which is nothing but a
mega conduit
and the millions or the tens of millions
that
are set aside for the meddling in the
internal affairs of other countries goes
to this conduit it's like a bank account
or something but they have a board of
directors and they
do reports and stuff like that but then
it goes from there to
one of four
private foundations one of the
democratic party
one the republican party or two three
the afl-cio and for the u.s
chamber of commerce
these groups then pass it out to
recipients uh in foreign countries
and in the nicaraguan elections of 1990
i believe the figure was something like
12.5 million
that went from the national endowment
for democracy through these conduits to
the
uno political movement there
uh it was the party the coalition you
know of uno which is the most ungodly
coalition you can ever make everything
from communists all the way that's right
that's right and then they had a trade
front trade union front uh which also
received money and then they had the
civic association civic association i
think they call it the civica there
that's a that's an old old
technique
of the cia is to establish a a a type of
civic organization which will be
involved in monitoring elections and
things like that and the first one that
i know of was nam frel in the
philippines they established that one
around 1950-51 as part of the
counter-insurgency against the hux
the
the guerrilla movement of the time
because we wanted to have a vehicle for
electing our man president of the
philippines
and we did it through this organization
then landfall stands for national
association for free elections i think
and yeah free elections when we were
financing
and
namthrow was very successful
and
our man ramon magsaysay was elected
president i think it was 70 52 53 and
unfortunately he was killing the plane
crash 57 and so then we switched to
marcos and various other
people like that but namthral never
never faded away and in 1986
remember the elections of 1986 which
marcos tried to steal well namthrow was
alive and well and they were the ones
who denounced the fraud
by marcos
and they then inspired the movement of
people power
which forced him to resign and brought
cory aquino in as president so now i'm
sure i was alive and well
they tried to copy it in panama
they sent the president of the chamber
of commerce in the early 80s or 84 or
there more or less in preparation for
the 87 elections i think it was they
sent him out to panama to study the way
namfo worked
so he could come back to panama and
establish another one there
and so he did
in panama it was called crusader sivika
or civic crusade
and
this was what was used against
the
noriega forces in the streets it became
what they call robbie blanca there
you know the the upper class white
people in panama it was one of those
organizations but they did take to the
streets and
you can remember the the pictures on the
covers of the magazines you know when
they had the riots and
and noriega was not overthrown then but
they tried everything in panama the cia
was running candidates of its own
all through the 1980s trying to get
noriega out
maybe not all through the 80s no they
his his utility ended about 86 87
because he was working with the cia yes
yes it was important for the contra
operation in um in nicaragua but by 87
everybody knew that the cultures were
not going to do anything they weren't
going anywhere militarily and noriega's
importance was in allowing panama to be
used for training them and also for
resupply but that was over by 87 and
that's when the efforts began to to get
him
aside leading to the invasion 89 but
they were
up to here in panamanian politics and
i'm sure they are using these different
types of organizations so the cover
action operations go on and as a matter
of fact in
not only in bolivia in bulgaria did they
overturn this government i didn't even
finish that story but what happened is
all this money from national endowment
for democracy went in and they fomented
student strikes and demonstrations trade
union strikes
massive street protests
and
not only was the money put in by the
national endowment for democracy but
also paul weyrich's
free congress foundation all got
involved and this is part of the
christian right you know he's the man
who runs all these different
organizations out of the same address in
washington dc
and this free congress foundation also
got going in there uh in i guess in
coordination with what the cia was doing
what ned was doing and so forth and so
the elections were in june
the communists said or the former
communists had won by the end of
november they were out because they made
the country ungovernable 1991 they did
the same thing in albania they had
elections there free fair no fraud
former communist won the united states
got in there through these different
organizations and the cia naturally and
they made albania ungovernable chile
same thing same chili the same thing
brazil in the early 60s same thing we
did i did this we were doing the same
thing when i was in ecuador in fact we
had two
coups
two
unconstitutional changes of government
when i was there and they were largely
due to what we were doing and by the
time i left after three years we had
what we wanted
a four-man military dictatorship that
was
carrying on a very strong repression
against the left
what's the situation in haiti now that's
a little bit different situation than
say nicaragua was well haiti is another
example of 1990s operations
aristide you know elected with two
thirds of the vote in 1990 takes office
in early 1991 he's thrown out in
september
and there's strong strong evidence that
the cia was was pushing this because
aristide is not the sort of man they
are comfortable dealing with you know no
he wants to elevate the
level
of the common people ordinary people
just like in nicaragua exactly he comes
from liberation theology and that's
always made the united states quite
nervous yes because in 1968 at the
medellin bishops conference you know
they made this prefer what they call the
preferential option for the poor
and that was a historical turning point
for the catholic church in latin america
i mean they'd already been doing very
good things certain people you know some
of the jesuits some of the others uh and
also doing awful things like in the past
associating themselves with the
oligarchs and so forth but
68 and this decision by the bishops
conference was really a major major
event
and the liberation theology moved
forward very fast after that through the
christian-based communities you know
that they established all over latin
america and these people were
dedicated to achieving social justice
one way or another and artisteed comes
from that tradition so
anything like that makes people nervous
because it means instability
and i remember so well all those years i
was down there working with the cia in
latin america if there was one one thing
we wanted and was our goal was
stability
and just as important i guess you could
say the second one is control
and
that's not possible when you get
a movement which is clamoring for reform
and aristide was trying to help the poor
of haiti
and reorganize the society that was his
program
along the lines of social justice and so
forth and so when that happens it makes
the united states very nervous and they
couldn't have him and so they had to ask
they had to ask the generals to take
over and not only did they ask them to
take over but
there's any number of reports and i
believe them that the cia was paying
these generals
running the military dictatorship over
that three-year period that killed four
five thousand people
and uh i don't know if you've been
following alan naren's reporting in the
nation on haiti but he's doing wonderful
just wonderful work
he
broke the story that um
emmanuel toto constant
who had been teaching on
liberation theology in the national
intelligence service known as sin which
the cia
which the cia established in 86 or 87
as a national service to be used against
the narcotics trade coming through haiti
in the caribbean and that area
which in fact turned into a narcotics
dealing organization as they always do
or often do
but anyway they set up sin
and
toto was
teaching on liberation theology in sin
how bad it was naturally it was
sinful
and so
he then is asked by
the cia and the dia
who are working together there
yes that's right after
after the
coup
to form a
a
let's say a militant action force to
balance the forces of lava las that's
the aristide
political movement and so they form the
front for progress of haiti or something
like that is known as frop
uh
you know
you know
f-r-a-p-h frop in front
yeah
and um so anyway they he organizes this
thing and the cia pays him to do it and
he's on payroll they're paying the
expenses and meanwhile these people are
killing thousands of thousands of
haitians all on our steed side natural
and it was it was just as dirty as you
can imagine and there we were behind
this and this has covered action of the
1990s i mean it's not like like um
rigging an election or something it's
worse than that in terms of human cost
and um
all this has come out thanks to the
digging of of alan niren
and the publication of his findings in
the nation magazine
so haiti
is one of those countries which the
united states
you know it's like the
rotten
apple theory you know noam chomsky talks
about this all the time you know if you
get one rotten apple in the barrel you
know it's going to spread to all the
others and so that's why they can't even
allow a haiti
as miserable as the country is
to reorganize for social justice it's
it's just
well another eternal shame on the united
states i guess but now that aristide is
back in
they're probably doing everything they
can to
to defeat his forces and it's not
working because in the elections that
just were held his his party or his
organization won the parliament going
away
they are in control of parliament now
and there will be a presidential
presidential election coming up perhaps
nobody seems to know because there's a
possibility that he might take his extra
three years you know and stay on
the decision hasn't been made yet but
i think the cia is going to stay in
there in haiti they're going to stay in
mexico they're going to
do what they always did communism never
really was the problem you know
it was never the problem in cuba
it did become a problem when
the united states the eisenhower
administration decided to overthrow the
revolution and turn the clock back to
the back batista days
it did become a problem because then the
soviets got in there they got a base and
they got troops and
missile crisis and all that but that was
in reaction
that was all in reaction to the united
states aggression toward cuba towards
cuba and are installing missiles all
over the world aimed at the soviet union
so i think that in the 1990s and beyond
we are going to see a lot more of this
stuff that we've known in the past and
one of the main reasons is that the
united states is imposing
this so-called neo-liberal economic
project
and
that is
also goes under different names like
free market and so forth but it it
results without fail and it's imposed by
the imf you know and by the united
states bilaterally and world bank and
all these organizations wwto world trade
organization now
and
it is imposed and it means in every
single case the marginalization of a
great mass of the society in a foreign
country these are
could be 10 20 40 percent of the
population who are redundant
they're not needed they're superfluous
because the industry that develops and
all the
economic development leaves these people
aside just like that is happening now in
the united states and is one of the
reasons why the extreme right movement
in the united states is growing so fast
but that means that there's going to be
resistance
and there will be people out there
organizing like the zapatistas for
example and others in mexico organizing
to resist
and that means that there's a role for
the cia just like there was when when
guerrillas were operating in bolivia or
wherever
there's a role for the cia to collect
intelligence on them to penetrate them
divide weaken and destroy these forces
and so we're going to see this i think
just like in the past the communist
menace was a bogey anyway in latin
america and lots of other places
and just look at what has happened with
the communist countries
take china big trading partner partner
now vietnam they're getting in there to
try to tap that 78 million person market
and they'll be doing it eventually with
cuba but cuba is special
they don't want to lose the idea of
control in cuba
and you have these
cuban exiles here the jorge masses of
the day who want to go in there and
run the country
take the burger king and the mcdonald's
franchise
and everywhere they go you just tick off
a list of these countries that have been
subjected to cia covert actions and you
can just see the
the uh trail of blood and and just
horrible things that have happened to
the people in the economy you look at
nicaragua el salvador guatemala
haiti vietnam well afghanistan
afghanistan afghanistan is absolute
absolute chaos mass
the
what you call in spanish sequel the
aftermath of of the afghan intervention
is
still going on today you read about it
in the paper every single day and the
numbers of people there have been killed
are astronomical the numbers of refugees
is way up there in the millions
and
all because
of
a movement which took control in the
country
back in the
in the 80s
and which was going to modernize
afghanistan they were going to
change the status of women who until
that time were men's chattels
they were going to educate women to read
and write and afghanistan at that time
was
was living in the past
with just a few
core sectors you know which had the
education in the west and so forth and
the agency got in there
with the chinese and the pakistanis
trying to support the opposition to this
social development program
before the communists took over in
afghanistan and before the soviets
intervened
but
what is interesting to me is in the
aftermath how many of these arab
volunteers
afghanistan is not an arab country but
they had a lot of volunteers islamic
fundamentalists from the arab countries
who went as volunteers to fight in
afghanistan
in afghanistan they were they they were
volunteers from algeria from morocco
from all of north africa egypt to sudan
and other arab countries and they went
there as volunteers and they fought
first they were trained in
how to handle the weapons and so forth
by in these camps provided by the cia
and uh then they saw action on the front
lines well when it was over
these they're called afghanis in their
home countries because they'd gone off
to as volunteers even though they're
from arab countries so these afghanis
so-called afghanis they went back and
then they started to foment
fundamentalist revolution in their own
country so you see what's happening in
egypt or in algeria right now this
algerian civil war has taken 30 35 000
lives they say but this is
being run and the some of the main
forces there have served in afghanistan
with the bill ticket from the cia
and the training and so forth
same thing in egypt with the
so-called islamic group there and of
these people who were tried in new york
uh on the two cases you know won the
world trade center bombing and the other
the conspiracy trial for the tunnels and
you know
i think half of those were trained in
afghanistan
so you see it coming home to roost this
is a typical boomerang boomerang effect
the other one is from afghanistan is
the great missile buyback you know about
that one no well
in the early 80s the cia gave about 1
000 stinger missiles to the mujahideen
those were the anti-communist forces
backed by the united states and pakistan
and so forth
they used about i think they used about
250 250 of them
so there were 750 left over and those
are pretty sophisticated well they are
shoulder fired heat seeking and they
were the missiles that that turned the
balance against the soviets or that has
made the cost so high in terms of lost
helicopters and jets and so forth that
they had second thoughts about
continuing in afghanistan it was very
effective but they only used about 250
of them i think that's the figure that
sticks in my mind i've got it on on
paper somewhere but that meant
there were 750 left to get back
and naturally agency said we'll take
things back thank you
and the
[Music]
we're afghanistan them together
and so they disappeared
and
bush when he was president i think it
was 91
1991 maybe both years he had to take
tens of millions of dollars from his
special contingency fund and give it to
the cia for buying them back in the
armed bazaars all over the place out
there where they were selling them they
know that the iranians got some and the
the thought of course is the danger and
the threat is that they're gonna
shoot down an american airliner
or two
with these with these missiles and so
then
then
carter not no not carter but clinton
getting my presidents mixed up
clinton harold they're all the same
uh
clinton then in the summer of his first
year in office which would have been 93
he also had to put up 40 million or
something like that
to the to give the cia especially to buy
back these missiles and it's i haven't
read yet how many they've been able to
buy back but they've got their people
running around from one market to
another to another trying to trying to
get in as many as possible
and that's the sort of sort of thing you
run into when you get involved with
these
kinds of people
i don't think they'll ever probably get
them all back because some are in the
hands of the iranians but
if they were so naive naive as to think
they could go to these mujahideen in
afghanistan high fellas we'll take the
missiles back
would you please
there's a final question people say well
we need the cia other people say we
don't need the cia some people say well
the cia should be disbanded because it's
hands are so bloody but we do need to
replace it with something else what's
your opinion on
the need for an intelligence agency well
first let me say that you know there are
committees on different levels looking
into the current and future role of the
whole united states intelligence
community because there's something like
12 organizations of which the cia is
only one and they spend
28 billion dollars i think is the
accepted figure for the overall
community budget of which the c i a gets
about three billion and so that's a lot
of money involved and there is a joint
white house senate committee which les
aspen was heading until he died
they are to report in the coming months
i think the house of representatives has
another committee going on it
groups outside government like the 20th
century fund are also
making their own studies think tanks in
other words and so
it's a it's a period of transition and
they are trying to come up with what
the structure and the
missions of the
intelligence organizations should be
and i think it's realistic to to say
that yes we do need an intelligence
service of some sort there are
legitimate targets out there which have
to be um
have to be taken into account i'm
thinking of international terrorism i'm
thinking of the international narcotics
trade i'm thinking of the problem of the
proliferation of nuclear nuclear weapons
and chemical and biological weapons mass
destruction in other words
and uh
others so i think that there is uh
certainly a need for an intelligence
service and organization no matter what
you call it
it doesn't have to be called the cia and
the moynihan plan of dividing the cia
between the pentagon and the state
department that still could
could be a solution but we'll still have
to have some clandestine collection and
the point all these years has been to
use intelligence collection to prevent
war
especially by out
by accident or miscalculation and that
was very important with this soviet
standoff you know
well
i think that
the most important things that should be
changed
and i don't have any hope right now of
changing these things but
the most egregious activities are
the
subversion
and overthrow of democratically elected
civilian governments and their
replacement with military dictatorships
of the highly repressive type that
institutionalize torture and disappear
people and so forth
that is one thing that
we should really try to eliminate
because it's a disgrace on the united
states the cia's support to murderous
security services around the world is
another area that really should be
looked into and these most recent
revelations on guatemala and the cia
connections with the murderers of the
american michael devine and the the
husband of jennifer harbury
the american lawyer
that is indication that these types of
support to these security services
continuing and it was happening from the
50s on i was involved in those those
activities myself in the 60s those have
got to be stopped and
then
the
i would say the
the third
area that really should be looked into
is the general area of covered
intervention in the affairs of other
countries and not just overthrow but to
to try to control and manipulate their
institutions of power whether it be the
press or whether it be women's
organizations or whatever and so these
are
my this is my wish list but
i don't have the slightest hope that
it's going to happen because i think
that all these cia activities are a
product of the domestic system in the
united states
and until we change the domestic system
in the united states
reordering the power structure here then
these things are going to go on because
they are needed by a very few in this
country few and powerful
interests
and they relate very closely to the
operations of multinationals abroad u.s
based multinationals abroad but it is a
period of transition right now
in the world at large it is the largest
in the most important period of
transition since the late 1940s and
early 50s
it's only a window of opportunity
decisions are going to be made now
about the use of the intelligence
services and a lot of other
international priorities and domestic
priorities in the united states and i
think that everybody who is concerned
should be involved in this but not alone
in concert with others because an
individual as in the trade union
movement you know an individual worker
has no power at all he can be fired and
replaced at will but if
you workers unite and a trade union with
strength then they have power and the
same thing goes in the political scene
or cultural scene or whatever else
other
sector you may speak of and so that's
why it's so important for people to be
involved
in groups the group of choice and there
are many activities out there to be
engaged in such as solidarity with cuba
to try to break down that blockade of 35
years or with guatemala so
there is something out there for
everyone and
we only have ourselves to blame if we
don't take action now
on our next alternative views we'll hear
the concluding
hour of our two-part series of our
interview with former cia officer phil
agee
we urge you to join us it's going to be
fascinating
but that brings us to the end of this
hour of alternative views
frequently hear from viewers who request
a list of news publications which we use
on alternative views and also a reading
list for u.s power structure in the mass
media if you would like to have these
send a stamped self-addressed envelope
to the alternative information network
p o box 7279
austin texas 787 13. you must send a
self-addressed stamped envelope
we would like to acknowledge the
assistance of the people that helped us
make our program possible
jamie otis is making a documentary about
the cia this film
features phil agee in it and jamie's one
who
was the facilitator for getting us our
interview with phil agee
the texas student television group
provided the facilities and the crew
we really appreciate the help of our
director steve khan he was assisted by
his technical director marty harris the
camera people were tony broomer
sabrina tubio and tommy kaiser
we also appreciate the help of don
cooper
who was the escort for philip a.g
alternative views is a production of the
alternative information network
p.o box 7279 austin texas seven eight
seven one three
so that's our address if you'd like to
write to us
and be sure to join us on our next
program when we have the concluding hour
in our two-part series of an interview
with xcia officer
phil agee
goodbye
foreign
and then i started fooling around with
this typewriter and i i thought
damn
i fell for it i knew there was a
directional transmitter in there and i
had to find it it was a transmitter
homemade transmitter
all
these transistors and batteries and
antennas and things all in notches
carved out of a very thin piece of
plywood this was a murder plot it was a
plot to make me disappear and that the
spanish services were going to do the
job this was brought on by henry
kissinger who secretary secretary of
state then made this long trip over
there i mean the secret trip over there
and uh forced the british to take action
against me and started a whole series of
deportations philip agee quit the cia
after 12 years the cia desperately tried
to prevent his writing of a book we'll
hear his story in the concluding hour of
our two-part series of our interview
with him right now
on alternative views
[Music]
hey
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
phil was in the cia for 12 years and
then quit after he saw what the cia was
actually doing all the terrible things
doing in the areas where he was working
particularly in ecuador mexico and
uruguay he resigned in 1969 to write his
first big book
inside the company or cia diary
since then he's written
five books the last one being on the run
which tells about his experiences after
he got out of the cia when he was in
europe and trying to write his book and
the cia was hounding him from country to
country doing everything he could to
keep him from writing this book
would you mind you i'm sure you told
this story hundreds of thousands of
times before you tell us your favorite
typewriter story about
sure i'm glad to uh i hope we have
enough tape for it because uh it's a
long story but i'll try to make it short
just the bare bones well that's okay
that's okay we have a lot to speak oh
all right
well what happens is this i am
just to set the scene i had left the cia
in
at the end of 1968 i turned against the
work but i hadn't any intention of
writing a book doing anything i wanted
to start a new life and among the things
i did was to re-enroll in university i
stayed living in mexico city where i'd
worked on the olympics and i
went into a doctoral program in latin
american studies at the national
autonomous university there in mexico
city is a huge one and as i
plowed through these studies month after
month doing the reading doing the
writing of the papers and so forth i
and i was studying you know the horrors
of the conquest and the genocide of the
colonial period the forced labor and all
of that the the the wiping out of entire
culture and then the
united states domination in the
post-colonial period
i was thinking thinking i i came to the
conclusion that
what i and my colleagues were doing was
nothing more than a continuation of all
this that started at that time nearly
500 years earlier
and
that led me to think
that maybe
it wouldn't be a bad idea to expose
what we were doing
it had been an unthinkable idea until
then nobody ever done it and i was
pledged to secrecy but
i began to think that maybe staying
silent on all this was
worse than
than doing it you know in fact i could
see some very positive things in in a
book
and so i
began looking around mexico city for
resources i needed to reconstruct events
to show our hand in events and i
couldn't find them in mexico city so i i
had to choose and i chose for the book
came to europe and
spent a year in france
and
i made a mistake early on i wrote a
letter to
the leading latin american or certainly
south american political weekly called
marcha at that time
and it's published in montevideo and i
had
i had mentioned how we intervened in
elections because they had elections
coming up and i was hoping to
to aid the french employer
with this letter which they did publish
and i didn't know they published it so
one night in paris to
knock on the door in my hotel and there
is
an old friend from the cia
and
we go out and have a few drinks and he
says phil i guess you know that
i'm here for a reason and i said well
yeah i think you are what is it and then
he takes out this thing he puts on the
paper and says xerox copy of my article
which was published in this magazine
this newspaper or weekly in uruguay
marcha and he said mr helms wants to
know about this because i had mentioned
it that i was writing a book he was the
head of the cia he was director then and
he sent this keith over to see me and
anyway i said don't worry i'm not going
to reveal any secrets i'm going to
submit it for review and all of that
i just want to get him off my back well
anyway i my my children were visiting it
was over christmas and new years of that
year
71 72
and so i
took them
and in the wee hours of morning went
over to the railway station and got a
ticket and we went to spain got out of
there
and then eventually they flew back to
the states to go back to school from
madrid and i went back to spain
to paris
but a few months later a young american
befriended me a felon whose name was sal
ferreira and he was a journalist or he
said he was a journalist an underground
journalist who was representing a couple
of groups in the states and he was over
in paris to
cover the
peace talks then going on between
ledocto of vietnam and henry kissinger
we saw
each other from time to time i was
living in a very cheap hotel on the west
bank just down from the sorbonne and on
the corner there was a cafe called liyam
and
he came in there and that's where he met
me i'd go down there in the evenings for
a beer or something
so i was desperate for money i was
really i didn't know how i could
continue working on my book because i
had i was running out of money i had no
money in fact to speak of just enough
for
a little food every day and i was
getting desperate and i had rented a
typewriter
from a typewriter shop at
odion and
eventually i had to turn that typewriter
back in to get the deposit back in the
meantime i had taken a big chance i had
tolsah who i was and what i was doing
hoping he might do an interview he could
sell the playboy for ten thousand
dollars and give me five you know
and so
he was he was recording the all the
stuff on about the cia and the book i
was working on
it was my only hope to get some money
and he did give me money as a matter of
fact
you know a little bit here and a little
bit there just to keep me going and
one time he invited me to dinner the
next week oh by the way when i was with
him
i noticed surveillance in the street and
i was being followed around from about
february of 1972 on and the first
time that happened that night i went on
uh very late at night i checked out the
hotel and made sure nobody was there and
took a taxi over to the area where a
friend of mine lived a woman whose name
was katrine in the passing section of
paris and i
i asked her if i could stay in her place
for a few days
it turned out to be six months or more
because
i had to stand secret
and so i wouldn't tell anybody where i
was living i wouldn't tell sal or
anybody else anyway he invites me to
dinner we go to dinner and he says we're
walking up the hill there
to um to
a room of todd and
he points out this english-style pub he
says let's have a beer there afterwards
they've got english beer now i said fine
so we went to dinner came back went into
the pub and there's a bar here and
there's a stool here stool here stu and
so forth and these are empty and he sits
on the one on the end i sit on the one
next to him we order our beer and in
comes this
rather attractive voluptuous young
american woman or woman let's say
carrying a time magazine so you tell
she's america
and so she starts to talk to me and she
is a venezuelan heiress
i mean an american but had been raised
in venezuela and her parents had died
and left her a lot of money
and she had just spent the academic year
over in
geneva at the university of geneva
studying french
and she was going to spend the summer in
paris so
she wanted to know what i was doing and
i said well i'm trying to write a book
and she said oh the great american novel
and i said not exactly
i said it's about american foreign
policy in latin america it says oh oh
isn't that awful often i said it's
partly about the cia to say oh oh awful
i can't stand those people that's
terrible and so anyway we talk a little
bit and she says well look call me call
me i'll invite you to dinner and so she
writes out her telephone number and
gives it to me
so i'm thinking well what is this going
to lead to and
uh i i didn't call her and i left went
through my routine not to be followed
back to uh to the little room where i
was staying and
about a week later i see sal
and to do some more of this recording
for the interview
it was notoriously slow on that it made
which made me very suspicious and um
he brings up this woman he said by the
way did leslie she used the name leslie
dunnigan did leslie did you call leslie
and did you talk to her and see her and
i said no no sal i'm not interested i'm
not interested here you take the
telephone
number and you call her he said no no
but remember she's got money
she's uh she's an heiress and and maybe
you could talk into
into into
supporting you and financing your book
i said well sal maybe maybe maybe i
should talk to her
so
so what i did was i i called her oh
hello how are you yes well yeah let's
have dinner come on over and i'll take
you to dinner so she lived down in mumpo
not on rupee todd
i went over to her place it was this big
tall modern building went up to the
studio she had rented and so we'd sit
around talking have a drink or something
then she takes me out to dinner
very romantic place with red and white
checkered tablecloths and
and and candles and everything and we
have our steak freak
then we go back to her place and uh
we're sitting there talking maybe
having another drink of wine or
something i guess and
it was either that time or the next time
that i decided to tell her who i was and
see if i get some money out of her so i
did and she said oh yes yes i'll do that
i'll help you i'll help you but you know
i can't stay in paris it's too boring
i'll leave you with this apartment
the studio apartment for the summer you
can have the key and here's a i've
forgotten how many thousands of franks
she gave me and i'm going off to see my
boyfriend in barcelona we're going to
majorca for the summer so i have the
apartment i have the money and all i
needed was some help because
i had to get a clean draft of what i had
done so far ready for barney rossett of
growth press who was coming through
paris on the way from the frankfurt book
fair back to the states in october
so uh there was another person who i met
in this cafe yams a french canadian
whose name was therese
and she was doing secretarial work she
had raised her children in the united
states she had married an american they
were divorced she had a son and a
daughter she used to talk about all the
time and we had a lot of political
conversations she was very very hip
politically
so i asked her if she would
uh oh as a matter of fact i asked
somebody else first but that's another
story the woman freaked out and and had
a nervous breakdown when i told her who
i wasn't what i was doing her eyeballs
started rolling around in her head and
oh god i
had she had to go to the american
hospital in paris
then i said well okay i'll have stress
so i asked her i just said sure i'll
help you i'll help you i'll come over
there in the evenings we'll do it in the
evenings after
after i get off work because she's
working in a law firm over there that
time so i gave her the address and keys
and everything and i would go over and
wait for her and she'd get there about 7
30 or 8. and this was leslie's apartment
and you can guess the end of the story
naturally leslie was working with the
cia the whole time and they were
recording everything terez and i were
saying in this apartment but uh anyway
we used the apartment she got the whole
thing done and leslie then comes back
from mallorca in september and she and
sal kind of team up together and
they're giving me money still she's
giving me money and then i finish what
i'm doing in paris i'm going to go over
to london to finish because the british
museum newspaper library this fantastic
institution has newspapers from all
times and all places and they had all
the local papers from the places where
i'd worked in the cia from the times i
was working there and so i could go over
there and read all the newspapers that i
was reading you know when i was there
and that's what made my book by the way
because everything we did
of importance came out in the newspapers
save our hand in these events
but that's jumping ahead a little bit
what happens is this
i had this borrowed typewriter from sao
which i was using and one night leslie
comes in in the rain to a place where
we're going to meet it was a it was a
cafe in the on the west bank and
she comes in with this typewriter
it's a used typewriter and she said phil
the guy who owns that typewriter that
sal gave you his back and he needs it
back immediately but here's one that i
bought for you from a used typewriter
store and so i said oh fine and i
uh i had to go back and get that other
typewriter from katrina's room you know
and bring it back over because the guy
had to have so i i didn't want to carry
this one i didn't need a typewriter i
was making recordings then for
um for london and these were operational
episodes maybe 40 or 50 secret
operations which i was trying to
describe on tape uh to use over in
london and so i um
i didn't need the typewriter i put it in
tereza's uh
apartment
she always left the door open she wasn't
there i just stuck it in there to have
it out of the way and then i went back
to get the other type of brought it back
gave it to leslie and then a few days
later uh uh we're at lunch and leslie
has given me the money that i need to
get over to london and last for a couple
of weeks before they come over
supposedly to help me continue working
on the book and doing the research and
sal says
overnight says by the way phil did how's
the typewriter that leslie gave you
working and i said well sal i um i
haven't used it
yet i didn't need it i'm doing
recordings right now and i left it in
tereza's place
well i got the money but later on i was
talking sal he says phil you know
leslie's so upset about the typewriter
she had that terrible cold and she went
out in the rain and got that typewriter
for you and you know we all know therese
never locks her apartment she's already
had a radio and other stuff stolen from
there and if the typewriter is stolen
leslie's going to be so upset and she's
already so hurt
she might not continue financing
so i took the typewriter and i took it
over to catherine's place and it was
there for a few days before i was ready
to go to london
and on a saturday afternoon i'd finish
the tapes went out to get a beer came
back up the steps and this was a this
building was where the servants lived to
a very elegant building uh in the 16th
tarranzi spawn which is the richest area
of paris and so there's a small maids
room
where katrina and i where i was staying
with her and so i
came up the steps went down this dark
hallway and there in front of her door
i saw these two people a man and woman
standing at the door as if they'd just
knocked
but as i approached down this dark
hallway they backed off from the door
over the other side of the hallway and
began to embrace
and to kiss it seemed it looked like and
they had coats on it was already i think
the end of october early november and
so i stopped at her door and knocked and
she opened the door and
and she started laughing to people and i
said wait a minute wait a minute i think
i think their monitors are something i
think the cia's caught me
i think they've caught me
i went in close the door and the reason
i thought that was that katrina used to
like to listen to the radio it was a
phillips table model
recorder
thing with radio and fm and all that and
for the last days
when she was listening to it there was
this beeping sound on the radio
and
i thought it was
propagation from ortf which is the radio
television center in paris and we were
so close there
but it was a kind of an irritating thing
it was like beep beep beep beep beep
beep like that and um
as i was standing there and these people
were embracing and i was waiting for it
to open the door i was hearing the
beeping sound i thought my god that
sound we hadn't even spoken about it but
i was thinking it's so loud now it's
coming all the way out in the hallway
when she opened the door i noticed the
radio was off
and so i said listen i was hearing a
beeping sound from that i was hearing on
the radio but i was hearing it out in
the hallway the radio was off
she said yeah the guy's got a hearing
aid in his ear
and they've got those bulky things under
their coats
and so um
so
i went in there and i said i'm going to
try to find out what's in there because
they found me now and she said well i'll
follow them and so they went down the
steps and she was after them but they
forgot that it's on the middle level
like on the third floor level or so
because this building is built on the
bank going down to the scene and it
doesn't have a street in front of it it
has this passage it's a walkway that
goes down and so they went all the way
all the way to the bottom where the
garbage cans are kept for everybody in
the building and there's a door there
but you have to have a key to get in or
out of that door and they were trying
the door and trying they couldn't she
told me that when she came back up she
went over and fiddled around with some
garbage cans and just watched them and
they whispered some things and they went
back up and out and disappeared she came
back to her story and then i started
fooling around with this typewriter and
i i thought
damn
i fell for it
and i turned on the radio and you could
get this signal
at several frequencies but there was one
that was really loud or strong and so i
began to turn the i thought that they
had df'd some kind of transmitter you
know that's how the
and that's how they could find the box
which is where they found me and so i
began to turn the typewriter around
slowly like this and depending upon the
axis of the of the box that held the
typewriter the signal was louder or
softer so i knew there was a directional
transmitter in there and i had to find
it i thought first it might be in the
roller or wherever but then i started
checking the inside of the roof of the
box
and i pulled off the
the upholstery and there before my eyes
was this most
amazing thing it was a transmitter
homemade transmitter
all
these transistors and batteries and
antennas and things all in notches
carved out of a very thin piece of
plywood that wasn't even a half
maybe quarter inch plywood or something
and it was an amazing sight to see and i
of course realized and
then i i had to get rid of a lot of
papers the next day and i i went out on
the scene and there was a little beach
there where i took a whole suitcase full
of papers to make a bonfire because i it
was too much to tear up and and all that
so i made this bonfire out there and i'm
i'm
blazing and everything and and
it was just down the river from the
eiffel tower and you could see it right
over there and i one time i looked up
and there was this guy with a camera
with a
handheld camera a motion efficient
camera he was supposedly filming the
eiffel tower but i think he was filming
me doing this bonfire with all these
papers and so i kind of freaked at that
but anyway the the
the
result was that i left her place and i
went over to mormont on the other side
of paris and i changed hotels for the
rest of the days i was there maybe three
four days because it takes one day for
those slips to catch up with the police
the the registry registry slips that you
have to fill out in the hotels in paris
and so i was changing hotels staying one
day ahead of the
cia and the french police and then i
took the boat over to um
took the train up to calais and across
to
to
folkstone and on the boat they were
waiting for me
the british
immigration and when i got up there they
said oh yes uh take a seat over there mr
agm and we'll call you
and so
time went by and i had all these tapes
on me
and
i had all the work that i'd done in
person a year and before that in mexico
and i i thought what is going to happen
and the tapes were very incriminating
and i thought they might just take them
away from me
and so it was raining like hell
on the crossing it was quite rough and
everything but i went up in that rain on
the top deck
i threw the tapes all my tapes over
because i didn't want them caught
or anybody to see them so
that was gone and then they called me
back to the desk and said
where are you staying well i had this
old copy of europe on five dollars a day
that everybody used at that time now
it's european hundred dollars a day i
suppose
uh it was it was the cheapest places to
live and so i had chosen some better
breakfast by argyle square
near near the station st pancreas and
kings cross and i gave him a wrong
address also taken but it was a little
bit more expensive than this cheapest
place so i lied to them and went on from
the train to this place and checked in
this bed and breakfast and this was the
most depressing area oh god it was awful
over christmas of
1972 because it was foggy and cold and
rainy and they had these yellow
street lights uh in london in this
section it was all old red brick
buildings in ugly and it was a far cry
from cafe au lait and croissant in paris
every morning but anyway i continued on
the book i i got uh the money
from penguin books and that solved the
problem then i just went on and did the
book and in the meantime the day i left
paris to come to
london
therese was arrested and i learned this
on the telephone because i had made
telephone arrangements to speak with
silent and leslie after i got to london
because they were coming over i
talked to sal
and he said oh everything terrible has
happened you can't imagine they picked
up the res and they took her into the
prefecture and they talked to her all
day about you interrogating her wanting
to know this wanting to know that and
leslie got so scared with this that she
went down to madrid i said right to
madrid she's got to come over here she
got the money
he said well i'm going down there too
you're too hot right now we've got to
we've got to all go down to spain
and so then they he goes down to join
you there we're on the phone all the
time they are calling me now because the
british pay telephones could be called
from outside you know they would ring it
so we'd make a plan and i'd go there and
stand by the phone until it rang
and so they went down to malaga and they
did everything they could do to get me
to go to
to
spain
and i of course was on to i mean i knew
even though i had doubts before now i
had proof and so
i wouldn't go but i said send me the
money and i'll i'll go in an indirect
way so i don't have to go through
airport passport controls and things
like that i'll take train i'll take
buses things like that and they wouldn't
do it
i said no i'll come i'll come i was
naturally going to just keep the money
wasn't going to go by any means to spain
at that time it was franco it was
fascism i knew the cia was thick as
thieves with the fascist
security services i knew that from my
own experience and so i wasn't going to
go but in the meantime i got relief from
penguin books and that changed my whole
life i was able to go on to the book
leslie disappeared
and sau went back to paris
and they didn't come over
and
then i wrote the book it came out and
after the book had come out maybe a year
or so afterwards i was in geneva and i
happened to meet someone who said uh oh
mr adrian mcdoran you know and i've read
your book and it is fabulous everybody
in ecuador is up in arms about it and we
knew all the names that were in there
and
by the way i think i know that leslie
dunigan
that was working against you in paris
this is years afterwards you know this
is like from 72 to 76 or 77 76 problem
and
i said what do you mean he says well i
think she's working at the united
nations right now but she uses a
different name here she calls herself
janet strickland
i said well how do you know she's the
same person
well my best friend is a spanish
guy who works for the u.n here too
and his best friend is a spanish guy and
she told her boyfriend who's a spanish
guy that she was working for the cia
against you and he told my friend and my
friend told me
and i said well
i wonder if we can see her
he said oh yeah i know where her office
is he was working for one u.n agency she
was working for the ilo the
international labor organization and so
we drove over to the ilo building parked
in the basement i sat in the cafe while
he went up to see if she was in her
office and she was in the office he came
back down so i went up the elevator
ninth floor so walk down the hallway
around the corner and i look different
then because when i was in paris and she
was working on this thing i had very
long hair i had a huge
zapata style mustache and
you know i was looked pretty creepy
looking but by this time i cut my hair
and yeah that was normal and
so i just walked down that hallway
looked in very carefully and walked on
and it was it was she
and so i went on back down got with him
and then i was back in paris and i
wrote up the story
and i took it to renee buckman an editor
at nouvelle observatory which is the
sort of time newsweek of france a guy i
knew
and he said he loved the story and they
wanted to publish it
and here the cia person was now working
on another name in the u.n no less
so
he said what about photographs i said
what do you mean photographers i don't
have any photographs of her
you can get some photographs of her
maybe
no no you wouldn't hurt to get you and
she together
i said you mean a
confrontation
i said yeah i've got two photographers
over there who are great people they
could do something marvelous we'd have
really good photographs i said renee
if you'll pay my way over there and pay
the hotel i'll do it or i'll try to do
it so
back to geneva i go to see danny jinyu
who is the
photographer a woman and her friend hans
also photographer working together and
so we make our plan and the plan
included um
going down after after this thing in her
office if we could do it then we would
not go to the elevator but we thought
there'd be a fuss so we would go down we
would find the stairway and we knew
where it was and we would go down four
or five flights real fast and then go
over to the elevator and down and out
and you know head the car
so we got it all ready and the night
before in the hotel i practiced in my
bathroom
mirror
the
most ferocious looks i could put on my
face because i wanted to scare her
really scared you know what out of her
and
so
the next morning we got in the car they
had all the equipment over to the ilo
barked the car in the basement up the
elevator to her floor down the hallway
and around the corner and the door is
closed where it had been open before i
said oh my god she's not working today i
knocked on the door come in
and so i open the door and walk in and
start walking over to her desk which was
on the other side by the windows donnie
goes over here to this corner hans
closes the door behind him and stands in
front of the door
and i walk over to her and i'm leaning
over on her dead desk like this and i'm
saying hello leslie using the old name
you thought i'd never find you
i said well i found you and now i'm
going to get you you could have gotten
me killed back then
and now i'm going to get you
and she let out this primal scream you
can't imagine she got up she went over
the door and we had this fabulous photo
taken by danny where she's she's really
big she was tall tall maybe in those
heels she was over six feet and so she's
grabbing him by the arm to pull him away
from the door and she's screaming all
the time she opens the door and goes
running down the hallway screaming at
the top of her voice we hustle out to
the stairwell
down down to the car and out back to the
studio got the photographs
they came out perfect
great and so back on the flight plane to
paris give it all to renee and it's
coming out on thursday about four days
later
thursday i go to the newsstand by the
magazine
where's the story it's not in there
and i call randy i said renee what the
hell is this and
he said oh phil i'm so sorry i'm so
sorry uh john danielle has killed the
story
and john danielle was the chief editor
he happened to be the man that kennedy
had sent to c fidel in november of 63
and he was about improving relations
and he was sitting in fidel's office
when fidel got the first word of
kennedy's assassination and
john daniel had told renee well we're
not in the business of exposing cia
operations
and so
it was dead and i didn't do anything
until more on this story until
november when my deportation crisis
started in britain and this was brought
on by henry kissinger who secretary
secretary of state then made this long
trip over there i mean this secret trip
over there and forced the british to
take action against me and started a
whole series of deportations but the sun
newspaper in london i mean all the media
descended on me in cambridge and the sun
wanted their special angle you know
they're the third page nude every day
the the mass tabloid newspaper of sells
four million five million copies a day
and so they wanted some kind of sex
angle and uh i thought well i'll give
you a story and so i gave him the leslie
janet story and
darn if they didn't find leslie dunnigan
they got their new york bureau onto it
and they found leslie dunigan a motel
clerk in georgia
and she swore that she'd never worked
for the cia never worked against me had
never even been to europe
and so it was obviously a a
a false lead the last question was have
you ever heard of a janet strickland oh
sure she was my best friend we grew up
in caucus together
oh so she switched names
jen strickland apparently was a real
name and she took her friend's identity
and so then they found the family they
were in an enormous villa in palm beach
and leslie janet was there it was her
parents place and her father turns out
to be the head of all the exxon
operations in latin america
and the photographer and the journalists
go down there and the father comes down
and threatens to punch the you know the
photographer and the guy he got a
picture and so the son then ran a
three-part series on this
the spy who
i forgot know what that headline was but
it was front page stuff you know
and that's the story and i don't know
where she is now
sal disappeared
gosh
and the circle was i told you it was a
long story the circle was complete the
oil man's daughter was working for the
c.i.a incredible incredible but in any
case
i have right now a
a lawsuit
going in the federal district court in
washington
under the federal tort claims act for
six million dollars because we found in
documentation that i received under the
foia in a long-running lawsuit from late
70s to early 80s that the
cia had committed criminal actions
against me during that period in which i
was in contact with sal and leslie
early 70s and the documents are highly
censored so we didn't get the exact
nature of this but
it happened that the cia tried to get a
criminal indictment against me when my
first book first came out this is early
75 and koble was the director and they
had to back down because the justice
department who which was getting the
facts to take to the grand jury told
found
discovered all this illegal activity in
the files they told the cia if we indict
and prosecute then a.g is going to have
access to all this through criminal
discovery procedure they said no no i
can never see the light of day
and five times in the 70s starting in 75
including when george bush was director
they tried to get an indictment against
me and five times they backed down
because this was so sensitive and i
think it's going to come out now in my
torch claim act a torch claim lawsuit
that this was a murder plot it was a
plot to make me disappear
and that the french the spanish services
were going to do the job uh if they
could get me to go to spain
that is sal and leslie not that they
knew what was really going to happen
their job was to get me in spain and
then
the spanish would take over and there
was nothing to them to you know
disappear somebody yeah those period so
i'm hoping i'm hoping that we will get
the real all the facts out
and find out what they're really we're
planning
that's ironic
you're doing some work now studying the
uh
for your new book i think studying the
development and the history of the cia
oss nazis and neo-nazis is that correct
yes in a way what i'm doing is two
things
i am teaching a course at the university
of hamburg
entitled
the cia the cold war and right-wing
extremism
and the content of those lectures and
that course and sources and so forth
they are
going to be a book
so that the lectures will be chapters of
a book and
i'm i don't know when i'll have that
finished i hope it's i haven't finished
next year but i'm teaching the course in
any case
as i go along because it's in
development and what i'm trying to do is
write a selected
history of the cold war
in
and show how there is a continuity
between the
fascist and nazi movement of the 20s and
30s and 40s the mussolini hitler and
various other countries
with what's happening in western europe
and the united states today
because
one of the most phenomenal
things that has occurred and hasn't
gotten all that much publicity except
with oklahoma city it is beginning to
is the growth of the extreme right
in
europe and in the united states
that is western europe and the
united states and canada
over the last 10 or 15 years
it's i to me it's really alarming and
it's due in part to the fact that united
states policy after the war in western
europe kept these movements alive
and they used the nazis and the ss and
the war criminals
to continue the war against the soviet
union
that is the united states took over the
german war against the soviet union and
used these people to continue it but not
as open warfare with troops and so forth
it was an underground warfare it was the
cold war and the cia was
one of the most important if not the
most important instruments in the cold
war in carrying on this
struggle against the soviet union and
all of eastern europe its allies and
they
were
carrying on an undeclared war for 10
years through paramilitary operations
and what happened was
as the red army was advancing to the
west
the people who had collaborated with the
nazis during the occupation of the
baltic areas of eastern europe of
belarus of ukraine and parts of russia
where they found fascists everywhere and
they formed ss battalions and it was
really these local people in the baltics
it wasn't the nazi
ss or waffen ss so much who
massacred more than a million jews but
it was the local people who formed
because there were five hundred thousand
non-germans organized into waffen-ss
units and these were the ones that
hunted down all the companies they can
find all the socialists they can find
all the trade unions they can find and
especially all the jews that they could
find and those huge massacres like babia
those were carried out largely by the
the local people who were fascists
before germany ever invaded a matter of
fact the ukrainians after the
the bolshevik revolution they formed an
organization of exiles in paris so did
russians this is the 20s and these
people are cultivated by the nazis and
trained and there's a there was a
ukrainian army on the front lines with
the german troops as they from the oun
as they marched in in 1939
or 41 actually when they crossed the
border but
these people retreated back with the
retreating nazi troops
and
by war's end you had something like 7
million
displaced persons or refugees in these
camps all over mostly west germany
and
the united states then began to recruit
and to organize from these camps and the
key figure there was
hitler's
chief of intelligence for the eastern
front
reinhardt galen
and galen came from a russian family
russian military tradition and
he had made his life's work of studying
the soviet union
and in his organization
which had the german initials fho that
means
foreign armies east in german
he had accumulated the most marvelous
records of any country in the world i
mean by
far and away
on the soviet union and he had been
doing this since the 1920s and he had
risen very fast he was only 43 years old
when the war ended he had a lifetime
ahead of him and so what does he do
the last days of the war he microphones
all the files
he puts a microfilm in steel drums
and he loads them all on trucks and with
his top people they drive from their
office their their headquarters near
berlin all the way down to the alps in
bavaria and they start trudging up
or getting the trucks up there and then
carrying these drums up into
a meadow where they buried them
and they walked back back down the
mountains and they waited
for the clark army to
come through i think it was clark
and
once they were in occupied territory of
the americans they left their hotel
or wherever they were staying i think
they're in a hotel and turned themselves
in
and galen he was a general he presented
himself as a general surrendering to the
americans
and he said i have some interesting
things to tell you and he had his
principal aides of course with him and
everything and his
main
chiefs of sections and all that they had
our plan they laid low
after the war ended
to reorganize later and so
they took galen to
camp king
which had
the the german name was dula gluft and
this is where the germans brought all
the downed pilots and crews for
interrogation it was just north of
frankfurt a big military compound base
well
we took over that the united states army
took over this base and renamed it camp
king
and there they uh
they debriefed galen on what he'd been
doing what he had and he made a
proposition he said i want to continue
my war against the soviets well the
soviets were after him because he was a
war criminal he was responsible for
interrogating uh or for the
interrogations of the millions of
soviet prisoners of war in the different
camps in germany and they died by the
millions but he was in charge of getting
the information out of them that they
were capable of giving and torture and
you know all that was going on
and so the soviets were looking for him
to try him as a war criminal
they asked the americans have you
arrested galen do you know anything
about him
you can guess the answer
no we don't know a thing
so in order to protect him they flew him
to washington
uh he turned himself in in early may of
1945 and by june or july he was in
in washington at one of the military
installations in washington stayed there
a year
and the counterintelligence corps this
was before the cia was established
set him up in business back in germany
and
it became known as the org
the galen
operation or meaning organization the
galen organization and then he started
recruiting all these people
including ss including war criminals and
so forth and they took over an ss
compound in pulak a little town just
south of
munich
and that's where they started up and
then they also
opened offices in different places under
commercial cover and so forth and cia
took the whole thing over in 47 but
galen was very he was the key figure in
recruiting these people from eastern
europe to go to the training camps to be
trained in military skills
as saboteurs and so forth and then they
were sent back into their home countries
to foment rebellion to to
[ __ ] economic development or recovery
after the war you know so there could be
this big contrast between eastern and
western europe these things went on for
ten years and galen was one of the
principal figures
they of course were never able to
to really
take control of any of these countries
but the
outbreak of
of violence in berlin
in the early years of early 50s of
poznan in poland 53 i think 56 in
hungary did a lot of damage in the east
east germany for example
they were often caught though and it
happened that one of the big operations
in the late
40s and early 50s was to overthrow the
government of albania
and restore king zog as
in power he was sitting in egypt waiting
to go back to tirana and
this operation
was a strange failure because they had
all these teams organized and they
brought them in
in maritime operations on the sea they
brought them over land from greece they
dropped them in from
black overflights what were known as
black overflights in them
and
one after another after another got
rolled up sometimes the forces were
there waiting for them and they would
they would double the wt operators
the wt the wireless
the radio operators
and they would then give them
disinformation to send back and of
course they were they were sending under
duress and
there were suspicions and so forth until
finally when philby defected uh
that's kim philby the soviet penetration
of the british intelligence service they
knew what had gone wrong because philby
was the british officer on the british
side for this albanian operation and so
he was telling the soviets everything in
advance and they telling albanians and
and so um
there are several different examples
there's one in poland also known as wynn
win which were the polish initials for
the organization
and
this was supposedly the remnants of the
home army the so-called home army that
had been under control of the london
poles during the war which the british
and the americans wanted put in power
there and the soviets refused and that
was one of the major factors that opened
up the cold war but for years they were
dropping in gold bars gold coins weapons
of all sorts and ammunition stuff and
until finally one day on polish national
radio they came on the air and exposed
the whole thing and the way it all
started was that they had sent this
general to london to say what his forces
were back in poland and they bought
and then they organized all the stuff
through this general who was really
working for the polls from the start so
there are lots of these cases and these
paramilitary operations were finally
ended
they were responsible for the
for fomenting the uprisings in east
germany in the early
1950s in the poznan
uprising in poland and then the
hungarian uprising in 1956
but they
the the radio broadcast to these people
had been ambiguous
by that time you know 1950 on they had
one
radio operation going to all the
different languages of the soviet union
and they had that was radio first radio
liberation but then they changed it
because
they weren't going to liberate anybody
so they changed it to radio liberty and
then there was radio free europe
which
broadcast in the languages of the other
eastern european countries both were
based in munich and both were hot houses
for war criminals from those countries
because not only did these
these nazi collaborators from the
various countries of eastern europe come
back and then
let themselves be formed into
paramilitary gangs to go back but also
they flock to these radio stations
because they had the languages and they
had the political background and so
forth so you had all these fascist war
criminals in the cia
funded radio stations
they were not known as cia funded at the
time supposedly they were private
donations from the united states and so
forth but anyway those paramilitary
operations ended after the hungarian
revolt of 1956 there was a special
investigation under eisenhower and they
they called him off but the propaganda
and the political operations
continued so in this book i'm writing
and in the course i'm teaching
i'm trying to show how these
efforts to
to continue the war against the soviet
union using the nazis and fascists and
so forth and war criminals how
these provided a continuity for the
survival of these movements which is
today so manifest in eastern europe and
western europe and in the united states
although it's a different situation over
here causes very large religious content
to the extreme right movement here
and in between to show how
fascist or fascist style governments
were installed in so many places around
the third world
and of course it starts in the
philippines and goes to vietnam
continues through the whole american war
in vietnam and all over latin america
and even in africa
in korea for example with the partition
of korea in 1945
i'm trying to show how there was no real
democratic principle behind this policy
it was pragmatic
and without principle really it was
simply to make sure that these
governments were on our side against the
soviets and that they allowed our
companies to come in and operate and and
so forth and so on
but there are so many fascinating areas
of greece for example
is one of the more fascinating places
because there was a very big resistance
in greece to the nazi occupation from
about 1940
one on
and
the
main resistance forces were
there was a coalition and the principal
or the strongest in the coalition were
the communists in greece
and the nazis formed what they called
security battalions made of greeks and
these were military units
and
they were
their job was to eliminate the
resistance and so it was greek on greek
fighting all through those years
and then at the end of the war the
british invaded greece because the
liberation forces the greek resistance
forces they took over the whole country
they set up an entire administration all
of greece and the british invaded to put
them down
just like the french invaded in vietnam
to put down the the liberation forces
there and um uh then they set up
a provisional government that brought
the king back and so forth and then the
greek civil war started because of all
the repression against the the
liberation forces this
this civil war goes on from 47 to 49 and
after it's over the cia establishes a
national greek intelligence service
known by the initials kyp that's the
greek letters for cia they gave the same
name and
this was formed with the officers from
the old security battalions
the
fascists
hunters of the liberation forces and
these are the same men who in 1967
overthrew the democratic government and
established a seven year
reign of military dictatorship with the
institutionalization of torture forced
exile of thousands of greeks and so
forth
italy another very
interesting interesting case where
even as the united states and britain
were the occupying powers in italy after
the war
they allowed the
mussolini fascists
to establish a new fascist party
which and it was fascism was illegal it
was outlawed after the war but still
giorgio almirante for example who had
been
mussolini's last minister of propaganda
in the so-called salo republic which is
a puppet
public puppet government run by the
germans in north of italy in the last
months of the war he established the
italian social movement or msi in 1946
right under the noses and with the
approval or acceptance by the united
states and britain they could have
stopped it but that party
survived through the years and grew and
grew and grew until it came into
government last year
and this is a party which states from
the mussolini party i mean it's it's a
direct descendant and it's run now by
feeney
francophini and they are a neo-fascist
party
they
in coalition with the berlusconi
force italia and the northern league the
three parties came to power last march
and a day or two or two after the
elections
feeney the leader of the neo-fascists
now in power says mussolini was the most
outstanding statesman of the century
so you see that there is a continuity
there and it's thanks in large part to
us policies because we were the dominant
factor even though the british were
involved as junior partners the
franchise junior partners and so forth
and
it's it's just fascinating to see how
these
movements developed and the the
the inspiration for the neo-nazi
movement in germany in the 1990s are
these old nazi war criminals like
otto reimer and christophson and a lot
of names of former ss people war
criminals who either were never punished
or were punished
with a slap on the wrist and who never
changed their views they are unrepentant
old nazis who are the inspiration to the
younger generation today
and these are the people who in
conjunction with the skinheads are
firebombing the homes of turks of their
cultural clubs and and killing killing
dozens of people
so it's a it's a really kind of complex
but quite fascinating scene and that's
why i'm i'm so interested in doing a
book on it in fact it's it's it's well
along
is your book going to include the
bringing over into the united states a
lot of these fascist nazi immigrants and
and setting up organizations in
conjunction with the republican party oh
yes in fact i didn't mention but the
the overthrow of the elected bulgarian
government in 1990 was carried out on
behalf of the weyrich organization i
mentioned the free congress foundation
that was carried out or led by laswell
pastor and laszlo pastor is a hungarian
who was
a youth leader in the most
fanatical of the hungarian nazi
organizations it was called the
aerocross
and he was a convicted war criminal he
had to he was i think sentenced to two
years after the war it was it was hardly
a sentence because he was
responsible for rounding up
he was involved in the rounding up of
tens of thousands of jews to send to the
extermination camps
this is during the 40s before the end of
the war while while hungary still had
this nazi regime under admiral horli
but now the horde regime has been
rehabilitated in hungary but pastor is
the man who
was
one of the major leaders of the
republican ethnic
electoral organizations and they went
into the communities
where there were
people from eastern europe and their
clubs and so forth you know in the
middle west and here and there and
this uh this ethnic
nationalities organization the
republican party was was
chock-a-block with fascists and nazis
from that period in eastern europe that
brought them over here but they brought
them over here for different reasons uh
the apollo moon landing was engineered
and organized and made possible
through nazi war criminals like venner
von braun
these people who came over and ran the
apollo program in fact ran the whole
united states rocket program from 45 on
had run the
the
underground factory for the v2 rockets
and there was a it was in an old salt
mine which had been dug out much larger
and there they created this underground
factory that was invulnerable to bombing
and alongside it they established a work
camp called dora it was a concentration
camp
and
over a period of about
two years
i think the figures around 35 or 40 000
people who died as slave laborers
to make the factory and then to be the
workers in the factory and
these men were responsible for that
and they were
brought by the united states over
to this to this country and put in the
same work
here
and arto rudolph for example was one of
the principals along with von braun and
they eventually deported him back to
germany and he had they'd all become u.s
citizens
several died von braun died but rudolph
lived on slightly long enough to be to
be deported and he announces u.s
citizenship in the u.s consulate general
in humber
where i live
so you had them coming back you had
project paper clip for example there was
a mad rush for the german technology
because it was so far so much further
advanced than the united states or
britain paperclip was the code name for
code name was for yes they had these
teams of army people who knew just where
they were going to go and they knew who
to look for and they've made this study
all through the war and so they had
targets here there and everywhere and
they were rushing to get these people
before the soviets got them
and so it's a mad scene at the end of
the war and months afterwards because
they were grabbing these people and
bringing them back as fast as they can
could and they didn't care whether they
were war criminals or whatever they did
they gave them new names in certain
cases with the worst cases and they
protected them they they violated
violated u.s law right and left bringing
these people back but that was that was
the day i mean that was the scene then
and
you know it's no different from today
who who follows the law today in these
things yeah and so that's why it's so
important for people to be involved uh
in groups the group of choice and there
are many activities out there to be
engaged in such as solidarity with cuba
to try to break down that blockade of 35
years or with guatemala so
there is something out there for
everyone and
we only have ourselves to blame if we
don't take action now because with the
huge growth of the extreme right in the
united states now with the militia
movement and the christian patriot
movement the whole
paramilitary culture these are the
potential brown shirts of the future in
my opinion and the same exist in europe
where the electoral parties are doing
very well in france and in austria and
in italy and in belgium and in norway
but here in the united states there
these extremist parties are not but the
christian right
which is extremist in my opinion and
they want to impose their own concept of
morality and all the rest of us through
civil law and so forth you know you know
that uh they have taken over their
control of the state republican party
apparatus in
between 20 and 30 states and they are
determined they've they said it just
straight up front we are going to take
control of the republican party by the
year 2000. this is pat robertson's group
but there are many others who are even
worse than that
the country is peppered with these
extreme
extremist organizations and all they're
lacking really is a charismatic leader
and there's one out there i'm sure
so we'll only have ourselves to blame if
one day there's a knock on the door and
they're coming for us because we didn't
take the opportunity when it was there
to make sure they never could do that
and that brings us to the end of this
alternative views
frequently hear from viewers who request
a list of news publications which we use
on alternative views and also a reading
list for u.s power structure in the mass
media if you would like to have these
send a stamped self-addressed envelope
to the alternative information network
po box 7279
austin texas 787-13
you must send a self-addressed stamped
envelope
we would like to acknowledge the
assistance of the people that helped us
make our program possible jamie otis is
making a documentary about the cia this
film features uh phil agee in it and
jamie's one who
was the facilitator for getting us our
interview with phil agee
the texas student television group
provided the facilities and the crew
we really appreciate the help of our
director steve khan he was assisted by
his technical director marty harris the
camera people were tony broomer
sabrina tubio and tommy kaiser
we also appreciate the help of don
cooper
who was the escort for philip ag
alternative views is a production of the
alternative information network
p.o box 7279 austin texas seven eight
seven one three
so that's our address if you'd like to
write to us
goodbye